crematorios improvisados como este han
aparecido en todo el país este viernes
india volvió a registrar un nuevo récord
de muertes más de 4000 en el estado más
poblado de india uttar pradesh los
familiares de un maestro de 42 años se
reúnen para la ceremonia funeraria
el docente contrajo el virus en las
elecciones locales del pueblo una cita
que convocó a millones de personas en
todo el país
el llamado sistema o gobierno o lo que
sea
era necesario celebrar elecciones ahora
mismo
muchos aquí afirman que el gobierno
local nacionalista hindú niega la
gravedad de la situación el ejecutivo
asegura que hay suficiente oxígeno y
medicamentos sin embargo las largas
filas fuera de los hospitales indican lo
contrario el doctor dijo que mi padre
necesita un ventilador pero no hay camas
disponibles en los hospitales
el gobierno regional amenaza a los que
se quejen de las clases se arriesgan a
ser procesadas esto que es por favor
dejen de llamarlo democracia las muertes
que desde hace diez días superan las
tres mil por jornada podrían ser muchas
más de lo que registran los datos
oficiales no tenemos más espacio en este
crematorio
no son ni las once de la mañana y ya
está completamente lleno el número de
casos se sitúa por encima de los 400.000
diarios pero el gobierno federal
descarta un confinamiento nacional